il ya un truc voilà dans l'émission de
thierry aussi qui a fait parler s'est il
recevait three stories c'est une
personne transgenre qui a conservé ses
organes génitaux féminins et qui se sent
comme un homme est donc cet homme ainsi
peut accoucher d'un garçon qu'il a eu
avec son mari également présents en
plateau regarde istanbul femmes mais
vous êtes toujours senti un homme
c'est pourquoi vers l'âge de 20 ans vous
décidé d'entamer un traitement pour
devenir un homme
mais après votre rencontre avec beef
vous décidé d'arrêter le traitement pour
avoir un enfant ou devenez alors pour
les médias l'homme enceinte alors ça
fait beaucoup parler ça sur les réseaux
sociaux si on a regardé ce passage avec
des amis nous étions choqués par ce
qu'ils pouvaient se dire sur le plateau
à l'égard du père qui a accouché
c'était quoi le but de tout ça pardon
miné où le respect dans tout ça alors
sébastien folin notamment à manifester
son indignation en recrutant aussi la
réaction de three stories sur son compte
twitter il est s'exprimer beef et moi
avons passé un super moment à travailler
avec les terriens et j'apprécie d'être
invité dans ce genre d'émission nous
savons qu'ils vont présenter des excuses
pour avoir appelé maman et j'espère que
se souviendront que beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres hommes ont donné naissance
avant moi moi je vous le dit et alors
choquée mais moi alors dites moi ce que
vous en pensez mais en tout cas moi ce
que je vois c'est que rive three stories
étaient très contents ils aimeraient ça
n'a pas choqué très franchement oui
la maman et techno mais oui la maman est
à gauche de l'écran on peut le supprimer
c'est une mauvaise blague et souvent
dans ses idées ailleurs assouly frais
des blagues d'accord là là c'est mal
joué c'est mal fait ériger accusé auprès
des acteurs mais j'ai trou j'ai trouvé
que lyn thériault était très intéressant
foot ça du tout non surtout pas non
c'est pas le débat du tout fait pas
débat du lac albert tuerai tous les
jours à l'antenne
ça c'est très bien si vous êtes dans
leur gueule avec nrj la tuer
je tiens prêt si l'on veut que tu iras
non nationaux à nantes nuls de dire ça
s'arrête des prêts reer vous sur téva ma
soeur est à tf1 je parle dans les songes
dans vos ça rien à voir je dis juste que
en l'occurrence puisqu'on parle de
gilles qui qui ce choc de tout ce qui ce
qui n'a aucun intérêt
et là en revanche pas de quelque chose
qui est quand même qui est quand même
dur c'est changer de sexe c'est quelque
chose de très violents pour une personne
n'avait dit
mais peu importe puisque surtout de
tenir c'est quelqu'un qui a quand même
souffert c'est quelqu'un qui vient
témoigner s'il vient témoigner de cette
cause là pour qu'on se foutent de sa
gueule à l'écran avec une petite vanne
perfide encore une fois derrière il dit
qu'il attendait des excuses et blanc qui
l'atteint pas sa phrase elle est
malheureuse mais palin terreur nature
mais en aucun cas la phrase elle est
très malheureux face à la menace et les
de mauvais goût ça prouve que la
personne qui l'a mise
effectivement voulait faire une petite
vanne pour se [ __ ] de leur gueule
toute une communauté pour la gaffe qui
choque pas bien compris même pas conclut
xavier mathieu a raison à ces caps à
tout moment où ça a blessé ne serait ce
qu'une personne ça veut dire c'est une
erreur ah oui la première sur les iem
mans il a effectivement mis ce tweet en
disant qu'il avait passé un formidable
moment et qu'il attendait quand même des
excuses
voilà il a rajouté dans un second tweet
que j'ai noté apparemment c'est moins
excitant de m'appeler le 8 198e hommes à
donner la vie ou peu importe le nombre
exact ce qui voulait dire que voilà il
comprenait que ce liner là c'est un
liner un peu pour appâter le client et
tout est possible une arme et meurtre
vraiment je trouve racoleur mais je
trouve racoleur biologiquement oui
effectivement c'est il considérait comme
une femme mais en terme d'identité c'est
tout le contraire qui dit il déclara là
je n'ai jamais été une femme enceinte
j'avais l'impression d'être un homme en
ce1 donc oui je trouve que ça bafoue un
petit peu cette période c'est dommage
parce qu'ils sont
ok vous sûr mais surtout il se sent
hommes mais la production refusa
provencher non et si j'en ai marre j'en
ai marre je réclame le droit à une
relative indulgence
oui la phrase était maladroite peut-être
mal à se met alors en faire mais tout un
pataquès et du coup ni et tout l'intérêt
du sujet et ne plus retenir que ça se
trouve ça assez dégueu parce que c'est
hyper important tout est dedans
ça veut dire que justement dans la
phrase on ne considère alors est
l'interview je mets toi le choc s'est
pas de signe quand même
regardez regardez alors pas choqué à
soyaux 1% à 38 % ils sont passés là toi
je serai avec l'ensemble des musées pas
c'est choquant ça non plus
[Rires]